[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Hey
Stephen welcome to the show hey good
morning or good afternoon guys how are
you we're doing great how can we help so
I'm kind of in a position so uh really
just kind of looking for some advice so
my wife was involved in a car accident
about a year year and a half ago oh gosh
okay we uh yeah she ended up being okay
she had some uh she almost had to have
some surgeries and everything and it it
affected her work she's a hair stylist
so she works for herself um she had some
hand injuries and things like that so so
we incurred some medical bills and um
some time off work and everything else
kind of but my question is I've got I've
got a list of our payments and what our
debts are and um we're expecting to get
about
$22,700 back in a settlement um from
from that accident and I was just
wondering if you guys could could help
point me in the right direction of what
we should maybe pay off or if we should
put it in our savings account and just
sit on it and continue to make our
monthly payments like normal U just kind
of what the best course of action you
guys thought would be yeah it's a good
question do you guys have any money in
savings right now very little so we
actually uh we have four kids one of our
kids is disabled so you know it's kind
of a it's a back and forth thing you
know okay so really nothing in savings
so how much what's your debt like give
me like a list of it in the amounts yeah
so um our house uh we owe about
44,600 on our house um we just incurred
a new debt which we bought had to buy
her a vehicle after the accident hers
was totaled um that's we owe 21,000 on
it uh we got a pick up that I that I
drive owe 177,000 on it then we've got a
personal loan for about
$2,000 and then somewhere in the the
neighborhood of5 to $5,500 in credit
card debt oh Steve you're not going to
like what we say that's fine no that's
what I'm looking for how much you guys
make a year Stephen about
75,000
okay
um yes
so okay can I say it before you give it
to him Rachel let me just say this
Stephen how' you find
us um I was actually just scrolling
through Facebook and and ran across some
Dave Ramsey videos and started listening
and how long ago you know these oh not
very um okay probably probably three
months ago if that all right so you are
like in the in still like in the uh the
entryway to our Our Gang right yeah yeah
you could call it the infancy I guess
okay so we're I I'll be super gentle and
kind okay I want you to begin to
transform your
language okay from we had to I had to go
take a loan out and buy a a a $21,000
car I have to have a $177,000 truck to
yeah we we chose to do that okay okay
that's going to be key as Rachel walks
through because the other when you when
you approach life as reactive life did
this so I just have to do this you will
stay broke for the rest of your life if
you say Come What May
I will stand firm on a principle I don't
borrow any money outside of a mortgage
period ever and a mortgage only if I got
to now you're about changing your entire
family tree okay okay it's about taking
ownership okay all right Rachel um
Stephen how much could you get for the
21 the $21,000 car have you Kelly Blue
booked any of these in your truck um
yeah so my my truck's actually worth
about
30,000 um in in today's market I
actually just looked it up the other day
and actually had the dealership the
dealership called me the other day
offering me 30,000 just to buy it out
right from me wow okay not interest not
not interested in doing that I mean well
I guess I could be you're going to
you're gonna get real interested you
might be in a second how about the
21,000 I I could definitely be
interested in that um and then I think
my wife's van it's probably right at
Worth right at what we owe on it okay
okay um and did you say you have $5,500
in credit card debt or
$500 about 5,500 okay and what is the
credit card debt what does that consist
of what what what were you what were you
guys swiping the credit card for you
know it it really I mean it was kind of
Christmas last year and then you know
and I listened to to part of the show
earlier when you guys talking about
Christmas you one of the 25% Stephen
yeah yep and I was really kind of really
hit home and then you know School Clos
and everything else okay okay so it's
just life okay so uh one bright side of
this Stephen to make you be like okay
you're normal you're normal you guys
literally are the Every American Family
you got two car loans you got some
credit card debt you got a personal loan
and you're just living life but you
probably feel like Stephen oh my gosh we
work really hard and I feel like we're
broke I feel like we're barely making by
how how is that possible okay so that
feeling that you're feeling is is a flag
that is raised
in your emotions to say like okay we're
not doing this correctly so the way you
guys have been looking at money because
you called in this show the way we're
going to advise you is a complete 180 of
what you're of how you've been looking
at money and here's the deal too Stephen
you have to realize okay I have to do a
180 because what I've been doing is
getting me these results and I don't
want these results I want something
different which means I my actions in my
thought process have to be completely
different now right so so what we're
going to say is probably going to
radically shake you up and you're going
to be like wait these people are
insane maybe a little but we're also not
broke so we do these things in our own
home yes yes we live this stuff out
Stephen so if I woke up in Stephen's
shoes and your wife's shoes here's what
I would do I'd sell your truck today get
the $3,000 go get a $115,000 car that
debts completely gone you got a great
truck or great car whatever you have for
15K you're calling it a day uh I would
take the
$222,000 that you guys have and I would
knock out the personal loan I would
knock out the credit card debt and then
I would put anything else that's there
I'm trying to do this quick math um
anything else left at the car loan so
you guys will probably have about I
think $15,000 left on the van and I Want
You Stephen for about a year to or no it
didn't have to be a year yeah maybe a
year to work extra I want you guys to
take on extra jobs either at your
primary job I want you to drive for Uber
Eats I want you to do the most radical
stuff to earn extra money and get this
van paid off because you could look up
in one year Stephen and you're a whole
life looks completely different but your
so I actually I actually just started a
new not new job a new side job if you
will good I'm a I'm a career firefighter
that's what I do for a living there just
frankly there's there's no money in that
um oh sorry oh shoot Stephen sorry I
didn't mean to cut you off we're going
into a break anyways but but but all
that to say this that's that's exactly
what I would do when I laid out for you
and it's going to feel different it's
going to feel uncomfortable it's going
to be strange but I'm telling you
Stephen this $22,000 if you guys get
this settlement and you get this cash
and you don't change anything you don't
cut up credit cards you keep living your
life it's going to be gone it's going to
be gone put it to good use create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life